I'm going to give you an idea of what a
grammatical rule is by helping you to
formulate a rule to explain a
grammatical feature of English before we
do this I should bring up two more
symbols that some linguists use when
analyzing sentences we've already seen
brackets which can enclose phrases
another symbol is the asterisk which is
placed before sentences that are judged
not to be examples of a language and
another's the question mark which is
placed before sentences that are judged
as questionable in the last lesson we
saw that English speakers tend to use
subject-verb-object word order in a
statement like you were there but verbs
subject-object order in questions with
the verb be like were you there let's
come up with a way to describe how
English speakers ask questions with the
word be and sometimes with have compared
the declarative sentence he has done the
work - has he done the work in both
examples
it looks like the verb and the subject
invert the subject and the verb seemed
to switch places when you ask a question
so let's try and formulate a rule using
the concept of inversion to describe the
situation in English and see how well it
applies English speakers invert the noun
phrase of the subject and the verb to
ask a question that works fine for the
example are you there but how well does
it explain the second example has he
done the work in that case our main verb
is actually an auxiliary with the past
participle it has done but the whole
phrase has done doesn't switch doesn't
invert with the subject only the verb
has does so we don't find that we ask
has done he the work we ask has he done
the work we realized that we don't move
the whole verb phrase we actually
extract a verb from its verb phrase and
place it before the subject now
it doesn't look like we're inverting
anything because the subject noun
doesn't end up inside the verb phrase
instead it looks like we're actually
just extracting that one head verb and
moving it before the noun with that in
mind let's formulate a new rule to
describe the situation let's say English
speakers extract the head verb from its
verb phrase and move it before the
subject noun to ask a question now we
have a descriptive rule that seems to
work for both of the examples we have at
hand
so we're going to change our rule
slightly to produce similar sentences
but the slight change we're making is a
move toward imperative logic extract the
verb from its verb phrase and move it
before the subject now this gives us a
set of instructions that if applied to
the declarative sentence produces the
question as its output this be have
question asking rule will work pretty
well until we get to an example like he
will have done the work on Friday we'd
expect will he have done the work on
Friday but we get have he will done the
work on Friday these rules are a work in
progress then I hope you now have a
handle on the basics of the grammar of
sentences and thank you for learning
with me
you